the Continental Tire Coaches Corner the
new Orlando Alliance head coach Steve
Spurrier joining us on the program coach
what are you up to well first of all Dan
I want to say I was very impressed when
you had on that mascot outfit and dunk
the basketball like yeah that was that
was impressive Thank You coach very good
thank you thank you so yeah I tell you
what this for me really it's it's a
perfect situation that's someone once
said what we get you back into coaching
I would say maybe a team in Florida
maybe an Orlando something like that and
it's like a 4 to 5 month a year deal
this is not a year-round recruiting guys
and doing all this kind of stuff
it's a Alliance got a deal with CBS
they're going to try to play in two and
a half hours 30 seconds between plays
instead of 40 emphasize safety no kick
off some some really good rules I think
that emphasize safety and avoiding plays
that maybe a lot of injuries occur in
and it's it's right here going to have
18 play during the time February March
April there's no conflict with college
football or NFL so it's a little bit
like a minor league for professional
football
there's many there's many many good
football players out there and there's
just not enough room in the NFL for all
of them so that's that's that's the game
plan of sort of right there and I think
it's a good are you going to reach out
to Tim Tebow if he's swinging the bat
and hitting the ball and he wants to
stay with baseball I can certainly
understand that but if at some point he
wants to start telling the ball around
and so forth we got it number 15 Jersey
Tony what did you say when you reach
down to him well just just basically I'm
gonna keep swinging the bat and I don't
blame thee say and I think we all
understand if that works out for him
then he can get to the major leagues
that's that's a pretty good gig right
there but it's not you know I think he's
flexible we're all flexible but
so so right now it that's that's it he
won't keep swinging the bat and stuff
but we don't play for 2019 so we'll see
worth we're all that in 2019 when's the
last time a college reach out to you to
possibly become their coach College yeah
they may reach out to you since you
retired
no no not college no no when I when I
finished up I basically said my college
days pretty much are over maybe being an
ad for football would be sometimes I'd
be interesting but I have any desire to
spend the time that these college
coaches stand now Dan it's it's a
year-round job it's really changed from
in the 90s the way they recruit 9th and
10th graders and it's social media I
mean it's a it's a constant churn tour
for those coaches and if you're not
watching as autism you're gonna get left
in the dust so I've had my runner in
college but this this sounds like a
challenge
see if we can put together a team and
see if we win the dang championship I'll
have a trophy and a championship game
and you know in life we need something
to keep the system as fired up and going
so this is uh this is something I'm
looking forward to where are we headed
at the quarterbacking position where do
you think we are in five or 10 years
from now whether it's college
quarterback or is the pro quarterback I
really believe it is very very helpful
if the quarterback can learn a bit and
can scramble a bit more than maybe in
the past these defensive guys are so
good now
it's hard to block them for a long time
but then again the quarterbacks that
know how to get rid of the ball and
decision-makers very good certainly they
can continue playing no doubt but the
college game these quarterbacks that are
doing threats and can run and protect
themselves at the same time I just think
it gives that team a little bit of an
advantage but if
who's the best quarterback you ever
faced the best quarterback I've ever
faced well it's a this you know I had
two years with the Washington Redskins
and we played Belichick and Tom Brady
and and we actually beat Washington
22:17 and I think right after that game
they went on like a 18 or 20 game win
streak something like that and I was
right when Brady was just taking over
back in 2002 I think it was so as far I
guess he'd have to be the best that that
I'm toasting yes but how do you explain
Brady I explained here in this first of
all a person a man that is very serious
about what he does I mean he wants to be
really really good and from his physical
conditioning to mental conditioning and
knowing the game inside out and this set
and the other
I mean he's totally prepared he he
invest his time to be in the best
quarterback that he can possibly be and
and of course New England they've got an
excellent plan for their players to I
think we all agree Bill Belichick is
this team and the way they do things is
the best so I'm a big admirer of him and
Tom Brady I think just total preparation
they do it maybe a little bit better
than almost anybody how about the least
important trait for an NFL quarterback
if I gave you running speed height arm
strength what what what don't you need
that much of least ability to make all
the throws but you can't throw a bullet
the answer catchable ball I think Tom
Brady Joe Montana Peyton's coming all
the jazz and on the records going all
the way back to Fran Tarkenton they
threw it and John Brody the guy played
bad six years
detachable ball you know it's a nice
barrel if it's not sprout it's very
catch below anyway and obviously putting
it where the player can catch it so some
of those big tall guy has it towed 100
miles an hour that's that's not I don't
think conducive to really good offenses
so that's to me a big thing throwing
that catch ball past each well you got
this kid out of Wyoming Josh Allen who's
got one of these once-in-a-lifetime arms
so what would that concern you that
maybe he he throws to part of a ball or
he throws it too far too strong of an
arm if they have a lot of how would you
describe your quarterbacking style
because people forget I think you're one
of four people to be inducted into the
College Football Hall of Fame as a coach
and a player
what was your quarterbacking style well
in college we rolled out a bit and we
had a little bit of a drop back and so
forth and of course back in our day the
game was near as fast as it is now so I
think I did sort catchable it wasn't
always a foul but it was catchable but
the NFL my style was standing over there
on sidelines I didn't get 10 years in
the NFL a backup quarterback and I tell
people all the time that's the best job
in pro football when you're out of it
though is that backup quarterback job
you don't get it
nobody yells and screams at you usually
the fans if something goes bad the fans
want to back up in there but anyway I
got a chance played about two of the 10
years that I was in I got you at 38 38
games in 10 years 38 starts ok that's
about right yeah 72 it got started a lot
and then what's the one you ran out on
ears not let your prom game yeah I'll
tell you right now when I played with
the 49ers the LA Rams
owned us and and I mean they owned us in
nine years
we're putting flush every year that's 18
games we managed to beat the LA Rams
twice out of 18 and I played in one of
them
Brody played me alone but I played
against him in then it was 1975 we went
down there and man just I asked oh snow
let me call the plays and I actually
asked him to let me play I was sort of
on the bed and we were floundering
around we're about one in six they're
about six and one something like that
and I asked him to let me play and he
said well you know you may get an acid
nonsense dose this I've been here nine
years I'd like to just go play against
and just to see if we could build and
say like about the middle of we said
okay it's all yours and he asked me let
me tell the place and I mean some stuff
happened and it was a game
remember Dempsey that had that clubfoot
yeah Tom Dempsey yeah Tom Dempsey he
attempted a field goal and our defensive
back Ralph McGill went in there to block
it and his foot hit him right in the
side of the head knocked him out
completely I mean we didn't know if he
was even going to survive it
he was out to get two hours or so with a
concussion but anyway they call roughing
the kicker on Ralph McGill and ginseng
went down there they Vista scored a
touchdown and he would then miss the
extra point so they were up 23 21 and we
put a little sort of a half-assed
together and we had fourth and four at
about 2:30 I don't know thirty six or
seven yard lay the child 56 yard field
goal or do you go for the fourth down
and we had
mecca Meyer our field goal guy he's the
breech and I think it's a 54 yarder he
makes a 54 yarder and we beat him 24 23
so that was my favorite game right there
we finally beat the LA Rams they had
Jack Youngblood and all those guys back
then and I mean they owned us a good
memory though coach that's that's that's
you know I remember that game all the
place Jean Washington called a couple
touchdown passes or snow let me put in a
little back ops and play where the half
that goes out and runs world war it's a
linebacker
and when I got into coaching that was it
was one of our favorite place
it's a man-to-man let's get that back on
the linebacker and Dell Williams called
the touchdown against him on that plate
so it was a that was my most fun game
right there we don't have a name named
for the Orlando team right it's just the
Orlando Alliance I don't have that yet
oh you're gonna have more suggestions oh
I heard one the other day embrace
embrace our hombre in Spanish word for
someone from your hometown and
acquaintance or someone from your
neighborhood and so we're trying to
appeal to the greater Orlando area which
is sort of the Orlando neighborhood and
if we're all that much on race fans
players coaches everything else to me
it's sort of a little bit of a rallying
word embrace we're all buddies we're all
pals let's go see if we win this game
something like that but I think the
Alliance is pretty much in charge of the
exact words but I think the fans down
there we're letting touch into some of
the radio call-in and all that and and
see if we can come up with a good work
there good nickname you'll even the head
hombre is what you'd be it are brave
they're tough hombres meaning embrace
talented embrace hey coach great - great
to hear from you and happy birthday I
think coming up what do you do 73 coming
up on Friday yeah I feel pretty good my
my golf games not as good as it once was
but I still ride that bike and treadmill
maybe a little bit better than eight ten
years old I've had a lot of time to do
that but yeah really looking forward to
the amount of American football I think
it'll be a very competitive game and
America has proven there watch football
television so this that's what this is
all about Thank You coach good to talk
to you again Steve Spurrier and ombre
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on Direct
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]